so devin nunes is back in the news we  learned that in the waning days of the  trump presidency the department of  justice led by bill barr  issued a subpoena against twitter to  unmask  the identity of the person that was  running a parody devin nunes account  called nunes alt now the department of  justice said that this was related to  prosecuting potential threats against  the congressmen  whereas twitter pushed back they filed a  motion to quash to prevent the subpoena  from going forward  and asked for verification of these  supposed threats which the department of  justice apparently was not able to  provide it's good that twitter pushed  back because this was clearly protected  first amendment activity  and apparently the department of justice  dropped this subpoena after  biden was elected so we're not going to  see twitter in court but hopefully we'll  see some penalties for the ausa that  actually  filed this subpoena because this is  nonsense